You have a Ferrari in your pocket and
you're using it to check the weather.
That's what most of us do with Chat GPT.
Open it, ask something basic, close it.
But here's what nobody tells you. Chat
GPT isn't an app. It's cognitive
infrastructure.
A second brain that never gets tired,
never judges your questions, available
at 3:00 a.m. when your real brain won't
shut up. One sentence in, an entire
strategy out. One prompt written, "A
weekend of work compressed into
minutes." But here's the real secret.
Want to make impossible decisions? Ask
Chat GPT to respond as your 80-year-old
self, the version of you looking back.
They already know the answer. They're
tired of the excuses. Can't start that
project? Let Chad GPT do the first 10%.
You don't need motivation.
You need a first draft. AI won't change
your life. AI plus you, that's
different. Watch the full breakdown.
Link in bio.